longueuil il veut changer le visage du
boulevard taschereau la mairesse sylvie
parent dévoilé un projet de re
développement et de densification qui se
déploie autour d'un tramway électrique
dans l' axe est ouest le léo le lien
électrique est ouest le tramway qui
relierait le cégep édouard montpetit à
l'est au métro de longueuil en passant
par le terminus panama et la future
station du rem jusqu'à la prairie la
ville de longueuil en profitera aussi
pour revoir l'aménagement du boulevard
taschereau les bretelles autoroutières
seraient détruites pour faire place à 30
mille unités d'habitation dans le même
axe longueuil ne chiffre pas l'étendue
des coûts on en parle avec fanny trably
racicot professeur à l'ena paix qui est
spécialisée dans le transport urbain
l'aménagement l'urbanisme notamment
madame tremblay bonsoir non ça alors que
pensez vous de ce projet est ce que le
tracé est optimale ah si le tracé est
apte immense on sait pas mais ce qu'on
sait par contre c'est que la vision est
plutôt clair et c'est une vision qui est
axé vers la requalification de tout le
boulevard taschereau
donc on l'appelle le lien électrique est
ouest mais c'est davantage un projet de
re développement immobilier qui a été
présentée aujourd'hui donc on met de
l'avant le redéveloppement de 25
millions de pieds carrés tout le long du
boulevard taschereau
parfois j'ai vu dans les images qui ont
été montrés qu'ils avaient une
diminution de la capacité routière donc
parfois il ya des certains espaces où il
y avait quatre voies de chaque côté
s'est réduit à deux voix de chaque côté
on sait qu'on va re développer tous les
stationnements de surface
donc cette composante le immobilière est
très clair mais la composante transport
et trait est un peu usé vous c'est ça
qu'on présente le projet lac sont
présentes qu'incitation donc certaines
certaines stations sont très espacées
l'une d'entre elles donc tout l'impact
sur l'achalandage le transfert modal
demeure et les coûts qui sont reliés à
seul stade marassi élusif donc citoyen
aurait été proposé on le voit dans les
images que compte qu'on présente à
l'instinct à mesure que le train avance
on change
la géographie autour on n'a pas le choix
de faire ça parce que le boulevard
taschereau n'est pas un milieu
résidentiel
oui absolument donc on requalifie puis
ça l'avantagé la requalification c'est
ça augmente l'achalandage aussi des
transports collectifs mais faut vraiment
que ça se fasse
concurremment avec une réduction de la
capacité routière une réduction des
vitesses
puis évidemment une densification
résidentielle donc les ingrédients
seraient serez là pour tous et une
augmentation de l'achalandage et le fbi
et le bonne option
est ce que le tramway la bonne option si
on le sait pas parce que les études
d'opportunité sont pas faites
le bureau de projet un travaille
actuellement à l'élaboration de ces deux
scénarios l'heure donc les impact sur
l'achalandage
sinon c'est très peu aussi sur les biens
avec les express les liens avec avec
toutes les lignes de rabattement donc si
quelqu'un à apprendre
trois modes de transport pour se rendre
au centre-ville et risquent de prendre
la voiture donc tous ces éléments là qui
sont cruciaux pour le succès d'un projet
de transport
on ne sait pas donc ce qu'on nous
présente c'est vraiment une vision de
requalification qui a un fort potentiel
et je répète qu'on a promis de cours ne
sais pas combien ça coûterait ce projet
là sa demeure à développer bien sûr
parce qu'une vision très large
est ce qu'on aurait pu s qu'on pourrait
développer quelque chose davantage
autour du métro c'est à dire de
prolonger la ligne jaune du métro
oui mais le plan de prolongement de la
ligne jaune c'était sur six stations au
sud et à l'est
donc c'est une option que
vraisemblablement été mise de côté
l'avantagent du métro c'est la vitesse
d'exploitation cependant sur la rive-sud
ont le moins d'achalandage donc c'est
plus difficile à rentabiliser
puis y'a pas aussi d'impact sur la
requalification comme on veut le faire
donc ces deux projets qui sont très
difficilement comparables un très
mauvais en surfaces coûtent
nécessairement moins cher qu'un métro
souterrain oui c'est quatre fois moins
cher c'est 80 cher mais c'est moins
rapide
donc si c'est moins rapide une moins
grande capacité de transfert modal la
mairesse dit qu'elle aimerait que son ce
projet là soient terminés dans un
horizon de 10 à 15 est-ce que c'est
réaliste
ça dépend quel composantes puisque on en
sait très peu sur le projet c'est
difficile de se prononcer sur un horizon
sur des coûts donc ça va vraiment
dépendre du
est ce que c'est la composante
immobilière est ce que c'est la
composante transports donc on sait même
pas qui est le mode vont du tramway mais
ces liens électrique est ouest ce
pourrait être un système rapide par bus
qui est alimenté par biberonnage on ne
sait pas donc le réseau temporis est
assez hasardeux de se prononcer là
dessus à ce moment là et on a donc pas
de chiffres mais est ce qu on est
certain que ça va coûter plusieurs
milliards de dollars que tel projet ça
dépend si c'est la composante
immobilière où la composante des
transports mais il ya moyen de faire
quelque chose avec un tramway qui est
assez raisonnable en termes de coût pour
un tel projet et son potentiel aussi est
ce que vous considérez que c'est un
projet à la lumière de ce qui a été
présenté aujourd'hui qui pourrait être
structurant pour longueuil pour la
rive-sud absolument absolument parce
qu'on qualifie un axe qui dédiée au
transport essentiellement routier puis
avec la composante immobilière dont on
peut aussi comme dans le corps de comme
on le fait on le fait dans le cas du rem
financer le projet de transport a même
là le développement foncier donc il ya
des très forts potentiels de
requalification et développement du côté
de la rive sud mais javaux dépens de
l'inter connaît l'interconnexion avec
les exprès ça va dépendre de l'aide du
réseau du réseau d'autobus qui va
alimenter ce réseau là donc est-ce que
ce projet aurait sa part du gâteau de
québec et d'ottawa parce que d'autres
projets structurants qui sont en
développement présentement oui mais je
pense que c'était ça un peu l'exercice
de de la république de dévoiler sa
vision maintenant parce qu'on sait que
la rtm vaut bientôt consulter sur son
plan stratégique de développement de
services donc si on veut asseoir une
vision et nos intentions mais ça permet
de mieux se positionner dans la phase de
consultation pour prioriser ce projet là
par rapport à d'autres mais quelle votre
impact en termes de transfert modal en
termes d'achalandage
mais il faut que les chiffres ressortent
faut que le bureau de projet puisse
produire les études qui nous permettent
d'identifier quels sont les meilleurs
projets fanny tremblay racicot
merci beaucoup merci à vous